サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタングブッダンササナン
よろしくお願いします
えっと 今日の話は まあやめたいことはやめられるということで
仏典に学ぶやめる訓練
えっと このテーマに裏にメッセージがありますね
今日のメッセージなんですね
で あの やめたいことはやめられる
いや すでにやめているみたいなこと
大体我々やめたいことだったら
もうとっくにやめているんです
私たちの行為は 善であれ悪であれ
全ては自分の意思で好んで行っているんです
やめたいんだけどやめてないというのは
結局は自分好んでやっていることなんです
やめたくなった途端 もうやめているんですね
それは心の法則です 今日はそれについてちょっと学んでみようかなと思いますね
よく我々は悩むことはやめたいと思っているのに
なかなかという感じなんですね
あれは嘘なんで やめたいと思ってないんです
そこで自分の意思で好んでやっているんですね
だから あの そんな気はなかった
そんな気はなかったと言って
みんな逃げたりもしますからね
それは仏教的に成り立たないんです
いたって簡単にこれ考えておきましょう
我々やめていることっていうのは結構ありますよ
もうリスト書けませんから
どうでも誰でも知ってるリスト一部だけ出します
燃えている火には飛び込みませんね
簡単にやめますね 走る電車には誰も飛び込んでこんでみませんね
どうなるのかと 面白いんだからやってみようかって
それはないんです 毒蛇とふざけて遊ぶとかね
そんなことはやりませんね
だから我々やらないこと結構ありますよ
結構あります この理由は
命に危険であると確実に知っているならば
皆自然にその行為をやめます
これが法則です それを覚えてほしいんです
命に危険があるとわかるものは
何であるともやめている
命に本当は危険がないかもしれませんよ
それでも自分がこれをやったら命に危険だよとわかっているものはもうやめているんです
というわけで よく考えると
私たちはやめているものがたくさんなりまって
それは人によって違います
これは誰でもやらないことを書いただけで
各自分では私はこれをやりません
私はこれをやりませんというものはリストあるんですね
そういうものは自分の命に危険であると自分が理解しているんです
これは確実に危険でなくてもいいんです
はい 次に行きます で 必ず行うことをまたたくさんなりますね
呼吸する 食事をとるとかね
これやめなさいと言ったってもやめてくれませんね
服を着るとかね 必要に応じて薬などを服用するとかね
やめなさいよと言ってもやめませんね
所有物を大切にするなどなどですね
やってますね みんな 誰かそれやめてくださいと言ってもやめません
その理由は 確実に命生きることを支えてくれると知っているならば
皆自然にその行為を行う
だからそれが皆様 ブッダの教えを学ぶ上で
この前のスライドとこのスライドに書いたこの 4番目の行をね
覚えておいた方がいいんです
やめるやめないかっていう問題は
命に危険があるか あるいは命を支えてくれるかなんですね
危険があるかないかではなくて
命に危険があるものはやめる
命を支えて助けてくれるものは決してやめません
だから我々は人に何かを教える場合も
このカテゴリーに分けておかないと大変なことになるんです
それでやめる やめられないという問題なんですが
これはそういうわけで
存在欲の問題なんです
存在欲 生きていきたいという気持ちの問題なんです
原始脳は存在欲と恐怖感という刺激を作ります
我々の獣の脳が存在欲と恐怖感をずっと作っているんです
大脳はその刺激を受けて生きるという活動をします
原始脳に生きることはできません
大脳が必要なんです 大脳で物を見て
聞いて 感じて 判断して
体を動かして 仕事をして
料理を作って あるいは服をデザインしてコーディネートして生きることをやらなくちゃいけない
生きることやっているのは大脳です
呼吸とかはちょっと置いておいて
生きることはこの大体やっているのは大脳ですね
大体ではなくて ほとんど
そこで大脳にこの獣の脳から信号が入るんですね
存在欲と恐怖感 それによって大脳が動くんです
だからやめるやめられないということは
大脳の判断なんです 世間は何を言っても
個は存在欲と恐怖感という 2つの衝動で生きているんです
だから我々は世間が言うことは聞いてはいるだけ
上辺で 本当は自分個が生きる場合は
存在欲と恐怖感が入ってくるんですね
だから 国のために軍隊に入ってくださいと言っても
まあしぶしぶ嫌々で入るんですね
かなり無理をさせないと
本当は自分が生きていきたいという気持ちがあるんだから
危険なことには生きたくないんです
はい 次のポイントは今日は早く終了しようと思っているんです
クリスマスやらなくちゃいけないので
やめたいがやめられないというのはどういうことかと
それは命に間接的に関係がある場合は優柔不断ということなんです
やめたいんだけど まあちょっとやめられないと
その場合は直接危険じゃないんです
やめたいものは 間接的に命に邪魔なんですけど
まあそれほどでもないと
例えばタバコを吸ってるんだけど
これやめた方が まあタバコを吸ったらガンになったり
病気になったりするんだけど
でもみんなそうなるわけでもないし
結構これ楽しいしね そこで優柔不断になっちゃうんです
もしタバコ 1本吸ったら直ちに死ぬんだと
これアルカリ入ってるんだとわかったらすいませんよ
例えば 1 日 40本でもタバコを吸う人にでも
アルカリとか青酸 なんて言いますか
サイナイドですね ちょっと入れて
これサイナイド入ってますよと
サイナイド青酸 何でしたっけ？日本語で
え？青酸カリ入ってますよとわかったら
絶対 例えば 1 日 40本も吸うんだけど
この人のタバコを 20本取り上げる
そうすると大変でしょう
もう吸わなくちゃあかんだから
あれは吸えない いくらなんでも
ということで この間接的に命に邪魔になるものはやめたいんだけど
やめられない 例えば嘘をつくことは格好悪いでしょう
自分の立場がね 全くなくなるんですね
それで生きづらいでしょ
嘘つきやで でも 嘘をついてもそんなに命に危険があるんでしょうか？という問題があって
優柔不断 はい これで我々の精神的な弱みが現れてくるんですね
だから 論理的なポイントは
命に直接危険であるものに対しては優柔不断はありません
間接的に命に邪魔する者に対しては
結構優柔不断になるんです
これ 邪魔だけじゃなくて
間接的に命を支えてくれるものに対しても優柔不断なんですね
我々は人を助けましょうと
ということはいいことでしょう
平和でいましょうよと言ったらいいことなんですけど
それで命を支えてくれるでしょう
でも間接的ですね ご飯を食べたら美味しくてもう健康になりましたというふうに
直接的じゃないんです
だから人を助けましょう
うーん まあそれは素晴らしいことですけど
私はちょっと今日は忙しいんだけど
すいませんねと出て行くんです
そんな運動をやっている場合じゃないんだと
やめたいがやめられないものも
実行したいが実行できないことも
三日坊主になってしまうことも
実行した方がやめた方が正しいと知っていても
実況力だけは現れてこないこともあります
これは説明する必要ないんですね
これは我々人間だったら誰でも経験あることですね
このような場合 行為と生存欲
恐怖感の関係が本人に明確ではありません
やりたいんだけどね なかなかという場合は
私たちにとってはあんまり頭がよく理解できていないんですね
それはそんなに存在欲に直接関係ないでしょうと
恐怖感にそんなに直接関係ないでしょうと
原発と同じなんです 原発は反対ですけど
全国民は結局は原発実行することに賛成する
どちらでしょうかと だから観念的に考えれば反対であって
やっぱり政治家がこれやめようと思うと
これ困りますよと だからそういうところで
すごい曖昧優柔不断 日本では結構曖昧優柔不断なところはね
ダム作るなよと 作りなさいと
どちらでしょうかと だから作ってくださいという場合は
生存欲を応援する しかし
他の状況を考えたら ちょっとまずいことにもなる
だからやめなさいと だからどちらかにしなくちゃあかんだけど
で 羽田空港もね あの これより倍飛行機が離陸着陸できるようにと
あの簡単に開発できるみたいですね
ただ 今は海からしか飛行機が入らないんですね
だからちょっとそこら辺
陸上からもうちょっと回転すると倍増えるんです
これって日本にとってはすごくいいことで
キャパシティがね たくさんなった方が
あのフルに活動した方が経済的にいいことで
大田区の住んでいる人々はまあそれは賛成なんです
そこで 自分の頭上から飛行機飛ばしてはいけませんと
で 反対するんです だから賛成でありながら反対ですという立場でしょ
だからそれでは生きていられませんだけどね
どちらかにしてほしいんです
で そこでこの 別に飛行機は上飛んだんだからってどうったことないでしょうに
事故ったらどうするのかと
事故ったら誰か誰か死にますけど
そんなに事故を起こすんですか？飛行機は
香港なんかはもう飛行機に乗って香港にもう着陸すると
もう飛行機の中にある私たちは怖くなっちゃう
ビルの上からずっと行っちゃいましたからね
今は違います 今お見えに作ったんだけど
そういうふうなことを私たちの人生の中でたくさんあります
そこで問題は 命に直接危険はない
命を直接支えてくれるわけでもない
羽田空港が日本経済活動のセンターになったんだから
それから何億も利益が上がったからといって
我々に直接大したことはないんですね
直接皆様のポケットに月々 1 万 2万円入るようになるならば
ものすごいいきなり賛成するんです
はい この弱みを克服する方法もあります
存在欲を支えてくれると心を納得させること
え これではもうあなた助かりますよと
儲かりますよと 例えばいろいろ健康食品とかね
こんな高いお金でこんなのを買う必要あるの？いえいえ
これ食べたら 1週間で血圧下がったんだよと言って
誰か誰かインチキの名前書いて写真貼って
もう見てくださいと このこれでお腹いっぱい食べて
美味しくて食べて 2週間で 8 キロも
減ったんだよ だからビフォーアフターを写真まで作って
あれスピード嘘ですよ
でもやっちゃいますね
で そうやってこの 無理やり命に命を助けてくれるんだと説得したらいいんです
逆に脅されることで優柔不断がなくなる
逆に脅しを使う どちらでもいいんです
あの中国式のなんとかの方位占いでしたっけ？なんとかありますね
あの あれ 何といいますかね
建物を造ったりする時
え？風習 え？風水 ありがとうございます
この風水とかありますね
あれって信じるのアホやと思いますけど
信じてるでしょ そこでこのトイレはこちらなの
台所はこちらにあったらもう収入がなくなりますよと
お金がいくら入っても足りませんよと言ったら
壊しますよ 台所 あるいは子供が病気になりますよと
家の大黒柱の短命になりますよと
なんとか言ったらやっちゃいます
何の科学根拠もないんです
ああいう風に この迷信やらいろんなもの
この世の中でね 政治 経済
どこででもあることで
ただ脅すか あるいはもう助かりますよと
これだったらというだけの話でやっちゃいます
だからそこで優柔不断が消えまして
風水なんか私はあんまり信じたくないという人も
やっぱり信じてしまうんですね
この場合は嘘でも信じることになる
で 有名な例を出します
私はいつでもこれ出したくてしょうがないんだけどね
永遠の命を期待して決まりを守る
すべての宗教はね 永遠の命
天国にあるんだそうとか言ってるんですね
だから我々の存在欲があるでしょ
そう存在欲あるんだから
まあその各宗教が教える決まりを大事に守る
イスラム人は豚肉を食べません
天国に行きたいんだから
で ヒンドゥー教の人は牛肉食べません
なんで宗教ないんですかね
チキン食べてはいけませんとかね
魚食べてはいけませんという連中
なんかおかしいでしょ
これほどたくさん宗教あるんだから
そこでわかるでしょ 存在欲が絡んでるんです
イスラムの人って豚肉以外何食ったってもいいんです
まあいくつか食べてはいけないハラールハラルの食べ物のリストあります
インターネットでありますからね
見てください あの キリスト教にもあるみたいし
ユダヤ教にもあって これこれ食べてはいけないとかね
私だったら何も食うなよと
断食して死になさいと
直ちに永遠の天国に生まれますよと
その方が理屈合ってるでしょ
だって永遠の天国極楽道あるならば
早く行った方がいいでしょう
それに早道はもう断食して死ぬことなんです
なのに なんだ こんな曖昧いい加減なインチキはと
でもみんなやります で
ユダヤ教とイスラム教は豚肉食べたらまあ大変だと思っているんです
この人の精神状態わかったのは
この日本の味の素会社が味の素か何とか作る場合は
この 豚の骨から作る粘りの何か成分がありますね
あれ使っていたんだと
で 使ったっても あれはもういろんな骨を溶かして
化学成分だけ取り出して
別に豚肉食ったことになりませんだけどね
という噂で大騒ぎしていたんですね
インドネシアで ものすごい騒ぎ
暴動を起こして もう大変なことになったんです
そこで全然使ってないと会社が発表して
もうえーと イスラム国に売っている毒ですね
あれは化学調味料だからね
その毒 毒はということを使ってないんだけど
使ってないんだと 使ってもいいんです
別に言っちゃえばいいんです
どうせあれをなんとかという成分が至って簡単に動物の骨から取れるみたいんです
ですから もう今も平気で使っていると思いますよ
味の素会社は でもあの人々はそれで安心してバンバン味の素を食ってるんです
早く天国に行けるでしょうね
だからこの存在欲 その場合は存在欲はちょっと桁違い
永遠な命というところに行っているんです
永遠の地獄を恐れて悪いことをやめ
やめることもあります
それから永遠に地獄に落ちるんだからと言ってね
でもやめるという だからそういうのは本当はもう明確
明確に嘘ですけど 風水と同じでどうったことないんだけど
まあ我々はまあやめたいことはやめさせてくれる
やりたいことはやらせてくれるんですね
このやり方で これは無知な人の生き方ですね
だから詐欺やらマインドコントロールやら洗脳やら
すべてこの世界に入っているんです
人を洗脳しないと人は言うとおりにやってくれない
だから戦争に若者が惜しくなっちゃうと
これは権力者が自分の権力を守りたい
商売をやっている人々は金儲かりたいだけの話ですけど
でも一般人がいて戦争しなくちゃいけないから
これでどんどん嘘ばっかりばらまいて
人の心を洗脳する アメリカ人だったら
国のアメリカ人のために死んじゃったら
もうそれこそ神様が認めてくれることやと
あるいは国のために死んじゃったら直行
天国やと そういう話に乗っちゃいますね
だからそんな大げさなこと今ないやと思ったってあるんですよ
我々も毎日そういうふうな洗脳されて
詐欺師にいろんなことをやらされていることは
確実に毎日日常茶飯事に起きているんです
そういうわけで 正しい自己改革方法をこれから
考えてみきましょう 理性と客観的な判断力は欠かせない
こんないい儲かる話に乗るんじゃなくて
いつでも自分の理性と判断力
それが必要なんです はい
それから仏教の話になります
判断して行動する ほとんどの行動は判断してから実行するんです
ほとんどと言ったのは
呼吸したり場合は判断しないんですね
これ機械で判断しないでできるように脳ができているんです
で こんな あります 呼吸しなくちゃと判断しちゃうと
心臓が動かさなくてはと判断してやっちゃうと
これで困ります あまりにも命に関係あるんです
その場合はもう判断も何もなく
モーターファンクションで応答で応答でできるようになっているんです
それ以外のことは我々は判断しているんです
怒り 嫉妬 激怒などの感情によって発作的に行動を引き起こす時も
脳の中で判断が起きているんです
時々ありますね もう我々も忘れちゃって
カッとなって何やったかわからない
何かやってしまうというね
しかし 仏教的には判断しているんです
ただ単に手を挙げただけでも
挙げたいという意思があって
挙げなさいという指令があって手を挙げているんです
そうしないと体がバラバラに活動します
今 我々の体がバラバラに活動しているわけじゃないんです
ただ 私はしゃべる時 こうやって手を動かしているでしょ？で
喋っている内容とイントネーション
出したいイントネーションに合わせて手が動いているんです
だからこうしながら喋れませんよ
今は意図的に判断してやっています
でないと それに合わせてシンクロナイズして体が動いているんです
だからそこは脳の仕事で
全部制御コントロールしているんです
だから我々の動き すべてちゃんと判断した上で起きているものなんです
精神的な問題があって
判断能力はなかったと
裁判で無罪にする場合あるでしょ
というのは俗世間の考えです
あと 精神病にかかっている人々は犯罪を起こしちゃう
それで裁判でまあ精神鑑定なんとかして
まあ無罪にしちゃうんですね
その代わりに治療か何かどうか指図することを決めちゃうんです
でも 仏教から見れば そんなのはありえないんです
頭イカれてる それはわかります
イカれた頭で判断したんです
だから罪に問えないわけじゃないんです
ただ 社会が決めた判断に従ってないだけの話です
はい 判断して行動するということを理解しましょう
立てはなかんでも判断して起こした行動です
感情で 気持ちで判断してはならない
すぐにブッダのアドバイスは
この感情で 気持ちで判断してはいけないんだと
まあお釈迦様は感情やら気持ちという単語を使ってないんです
煩悩という汚れという言葉しか使ってないんだけど
現代用語に入れ替えると
それは感情ということになるんですね
感情で判断してはいけない
感情と自分の気持ちの判断は決まって間違っているんです
それは間違っています
なぜ間違っているんですかね
この感情 煩悩っていうのは
この原始脳の仕事なんです
理屈ないんです 怒り 嫉妬
憎しみ 大脳にもありますよ
これは大脳が感染しているんです
だから生まれる前に原始脳ができているんだから
もう回路もないんですよ
もう全部細胞ぴったし
もうプラグインしたような状態でもうできているんです
そちらに考える能力ないんです
あるのは生きていきたい
それから恐怖感 生きていきたいとは死にたくないということだから
いつも両方 恐怖感と存在欲が一緒にやっているんです
それに枝分かれになっちゃって
様々な感情が生まれるんです
恐怖感というのは 怒りになったり
嫉妬になったり 落ち込みになったり
後悔になったり いろいろ枝分かれになります
人を軽蔑したり で 存在欲は傲慢になったり
自分を大きく見せようとしたり
自分のないとこもある
あるなあるのごとく言いふらしたり
いろいろ感情が枝分かれするんです
どちらにも理論がないんです
例えば 自分にないいろんな能力やら資格やらあるのをごとく言いふらす場合は何なのか
あれは これ大脳やってますけど
で 卒業しましたとかね
そういう証明書をごまかしたりとかね
存在欲なんです ただ存在欲でやってるんです
ですから この 感情煩悩というのは 1510 ありますからね
まあそこまで覚えなくても
基本的には貪瞋痴ですからね
その考える能力のない原始の感情で判断してはいけません
それは間違っています
怒ったら殴りますと 怒ったら人を怒鳴りますと
殴ったり怒鳴ったりするのは大脳です
判断するのは大脳です
しかし 判断するために必要なデータが自分の怒りなんです
だって私は怒ったんだからと言うんです
あんたは怒ったんだからって
なんで人を殴るんですかと
理論成り立ってないんです
だから仏教では決して感情で
気持ちで判断してはいけないということにしているんです
自分の存在欲と自分の恐怖心だけが判断する
その時判断する審判官が存在欲と恐怖感なんですね
これとても危険なことで
命は自分の都合だけで成り立たないんです
だから自分勝手に判断しても生きていきたいんだから判断しました
生きていきたいんだから横領しましたとかね
ライバル会社に何かスパイを入れたり
ハッキングしたり いろいろ邪魔をしました
それは自分の会社を成長して
自分が生きていきたいんだからなんです
で そんなことをやっても
これは愚かな判断で 微塵も理性がない判断で
生きるということはそんなもので成り立たないんです
だからよく見てください
生きるということは 私の都合で成り立つものじゃないんです
世間の因果関係によって成り立つんです
自分が生きていきたいんだから
自分の会社が儲かりたいんだから
ライバル会社のシステムをハッキングしたらどうなるんですかね
世間は別な態度を取りますからね
これを反 凡才であると
だから弁償しなさいと
と言って ものすごい金額を弁償する羽目になる
自分の業務停止させる
終わりでしょ 全部 だから我々は人生台無しになることを結構やってしまいますね
理由は感情で判断しているからなんです
だから まず我々は生きることは自分の都合で成り立たないんだと理解しなくてはいけないんです
世間で因果法則があるんです
例えば空気が汚れたとすると
いくら生きていきたくても生きていられないんです
体で感じなくても 放射能で被曝すると細胞が壊れるんです
だから生きるということは
世間というのは人間だけではなくて
すべて自然環境 すべて世間ですね
この世間との因果関係の結果で
私一人の努力じゃないんです
これは日本では間違った単語を使っても生かされているんだと
生きているのではないんだと
生かされるという言葉は仏教的ではないんです
因縁法則によって命が成り立っている
それが正しいフレーズなんです
生かされていると 誰に？と聞きたくなるでしょ
それは間違っている 誰も生かしてくれてないんです
自分を 誰も ただ因縁関係によって生きているだけです
判断するときは客観的なデータを参考にしましょう
ですから 客観的なデータを参考して
怒り 嫉妬で判断しない
欲で判断しない 存在欲で
私は生きていきたい 私は儲かりたい
私は人気者になりたい
だからといって判断しない
客観的なデータで判断する
はい これからちょっとお釈迦様の言葉紹介します
これはちゃんとしたお釈迦様の言葉の一部をカットしました
このアッスッタワ・プトゥッジャナという単語
これはお釈迦様は何か説法するために形容詞として使うフレーズで
別に仏教内容あるわけじゃないんですけど
アッスッタワ・プトゥッジャナというのは
学ぶことはない一般の人々という意味なんですね
この学ぶことを仏教はとても大事にするんです
その人々はヤターブータンナパッセティ
物事をありのままに見ない
判断しない だからこれはブッダの教えを学んでいる人々は
こちらに入らないんです
世の中は決して物事をありのままに客観的に判断しない
聖書に基づいて判断する
なんだこりゃと それでアリーヤ・サーアウコ
アリーヤ・ダンマ・サコーウィド
ヤターブータン・パッセティ
聖者の弟子 聖者の教えを学んだ人は
ありのままに客観的に物事を見て判断するんです
これでこの問題は解決する
ありのままに見なさいよと
私の原始脳の感情で生きているんじゃないんだと
すべての人間が原始脳の感情で
刺激で大脳が動かしちゃって
大脳の指令で生きているんです
しかし 大脳がただ原始脳の奴隷なんです
獣の奴隷なんです だから人類は獣に支配されているんです
これやめましょうよと
客観的に判断することにしましょう
というのは仏教の提案なんです
はい 次 このやめたい やめるべきものはどうやってやめるのかという方法を教えていきます
幸福を目的にするんです
理性で考えるならば 存在欲は成り立たない
じゃあ ありのままに客観的に考えましょう
私は生きていきたい 客観的なデータは
あなたはいつか必ず死ぬんだよと
今日はインターネットで国のあるプログラムを見ていたんですね
そちらにあった話 あれは冗談の話ではないんだけど
一つ伝統的な音楽のプログラムでしたけどね
その内容は面白かったんです
この 王様のところにこの泥棒が捕まってきて
そこで審判して 王様がすごい怒って
お前はね これこれこれぐらい泥棒やってね
こんな大変なことをやっちゃって
だからお前死刑にするんだと
死刑決めるんです で あんたに何か言いたいことあるのかと
したら この人歌を歌うんですね
王様も王様の仕事 苦労して王様の仕事をしているんだよと
して 必ず死にますよと
私は泥棒で泥棒とて結構苦労して生きているんだよと
王様は選んではなくて道じゃなくて
どうしようもなく王になったんだから
王様の仕事をするんだと
私も私にも生きる方法はないんだから
泥棒の道を選んで それ結構苦労していますよと
王様もそうでしょうにと
結構苦労しているんだよと
しかし あなたも死にますよ
私も死にますよと 他の人々もみんな必ず死にますよと
ですから どうせ死ぬんだから
私に罰を与えたければ
これは罰になりませんよと
別な罰を与えてくださいと
いう なんか仏教的な意味も入っている伝統的な歌でしたけど
だってどうしたって死ぬんだから
もう殺したっても これは罰になりませんよと
だってあなたも死ぬでしょうにと王様にも言うんです
ですから どうしても王様が私に罰を与えたければ
別なことにしてくださいよと
いう話なんですね で 全然冗談にならなかったね
そんなもんですね もう寒い時はね
寒い冗談言っても 理性で考えると誰だって死ぬんです
だから死にたくない 死にたくないっていうのはあまりもアホな希望でしょ？だから如実にありのままにヤタブータで物事を見るならば
その項目を捨てる 生きたい生きたい
どうしてもという したがって
恐怖感は無意味で無駄な感情です
恐怖感というのは死ぬのは怖いでしょ
そこから現れるでしょう
すべての恐怖感の親は死ぬのが怖いなんです
インフルエンザにかかるのも怖いでしょ
死ぬのは怖いんだからなんです
だからどうしたっても死ぬんだよと
思ったら 別に怖がって怯えて
恐怖感で頭イカれるまで恐怖感で
なんだこりゃと 心はしっかりします
だからありのままに見る
それから生きることは苦です
生きることは苦です しかし
苦は避けたいでしょ これはありのままに見る世界なんです
皆様方と言ったっても
みんな世間の人間が死ぬのは怖くて死から逃げたいんですね
仏教の場合は 苦しみから逃げるようにしてくださいと
テーマ変えるんです 微妙に変えるんです
幸福とは何？幸福に生きることは何？と考えるんです
だから答えはいたって簡単
生まれた 生まれた時は死ぬことも決めた
もう変われない もう定めているんです
そのポイントもあの歌の中にあったんです
あのね 王様は生まれる時はどう死ぬかともう決まっている
だから王様もいつどんな風に死ぬかともう決まっているんだよ
私もどんな風に死ぬのかとか
決まっているんだと だから決まっていることを指令するんですかと
いうことで王様を馬鹿にしちゃったんです
あの人は 泥棒が だったら
理性の答えは何ですか？生まれた
決まった日で死ぬ これは変わりません
変更できません だったらこの間どうするのかと
この間できるだけ苦を避けて生きるんです
だからそれ考えるんです
幸福を目的にすると理性が現れます
まあいつ死んだってもいいや
私は楽しく幸福で生きてみますと
いたって簡単でしょ この方法は
難しくないでしょ 私は幸福に生きてみますと決めたら
理性が現れます あの もう原始脳はもう後回しにしているんです
存在欲では生きていきません
恐怖感で生きることはしません
やめろ こんなバカバカらしいと
決して成り立たないんだと
だからその瞬間で 各宗教に対する皆様の怯えも尊敬も消えます
あれってまるっきり人を馬鹿にしているんです
あの この世で死ぬんだから
天国で永遠に生きられるんだと
ありえないでしょうに
どこか生まれたらもう変化していくというのが正しい法則でしょうに
天国はあったとしたっても永遠ではないんです
地獄はあると仏教の経典にもありますよ
しかし 一つも永遠ではないんです
そこで客観的に見ることも
判断することもできるようになります
はい これが仏教の答えなんですよ
いたって簡単 それで 幸福になることはやる
不幸になることをやめる
苦しみになることをやめる
楽になることをやる それだけ
目的を決めたら はい これに
これは仏教の中道 小道とも言いますけどの立場なんです
あの中道というのは真ん中ではなくて
超越という意味なんです
聖者が発見した道という意味なんです
行為をするしないとは
存在欲と恐怖感の選択です
だから仏教はするしないということは問題にしないんです
これこれしなさい これこれしてはいけませんとか
そんなのはあんまりないんです
この 2つを応援するとは
獣のレベルで生き続けることになります
だから 存在欲を応援して
これこれやりなさい 恐怖感で脅して
これこれやめなさいと言っても
獣は獣なんです だから世の中にも立派なこといっぱいありますよ
宗教もいいことを教えているし
普通の社会でも結構いいことを教えていますけど
そんなもの乗ったっても
人間の獣度は変わりません
直ちに捨てられる感情でもありません
それから 存在欲と恐怖感というのはピシッと捨てることもできません
はい 捨てますと言ったっても
ありのままに見なさいと私は説明したでしょうに
でも 人は誰だって死にましょうとわかっても
やっぱり存在欲がまだまだ隠れているんです
だからいきなりお釈迦様が存在欲を捨てなさいとは言わないんです
ですから 苦を乗り越えて幸福に達することを目指すんです
そこは置いておいて 別な目的を作るんです
苦を乗り越えましょう
幸福に達しましょうと
人間にいまだかつてなかった新たな課題を与えるんです
世間に宗教の世界にあったのは
永遠になるという目的なんです
それはお釈迦様が微妙に変えるんです
幸福になりなさいと よく理解してください
皆様はものすごく立派な仏教徒になるんです
存在欲と恐怖感を超越した生き方になります
否定も肯定もする立場ではありません
だから この立場 幸福になりなさいと新たな課題を選ぶことは
存在欲と恐怖感という極端を捨てて
超越道に入ったことになります
これでも仏道に入ったことになります
はい 次 私は幸福ですか
見えますかね ちょっと見づらいでしょうか
効用する前に唱える呪文です
呪文という言葉は冗談で入れたんだけど
で 真剣に考える必要はないんで
呪文のように唱えてくださいなんです
本物の呪文です 私は幸福ですか？と
悪感情に打ち勝つ 打ち勝つためにチェックを入れる
まず心に様々な感情が湧きますね
だからまだ心治ってないんだからね
原始の元気だからね 感情が湧きます
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ 欲求 傲慢
見えなどなどの 1,500 の感情が湧きます
その時 この感情でいる私は幸福
楽しみ 安らぎを感じていますか？苦しみ
不幸を感じていますかとチェックします
いたって簡単 例えば 怒りがこみ上げてきた
今私は幸福 今私は楽しい
今私は安らぎを感じていると自分に聞いてみてください
そうするとないということにチェック入れるはずなんです
気分が悪くなってくる
人が言ったことで みんな引っかかるでしょ
その時は失敗しますね
必ずこの場合 失敗しません
人が何言ったっても 自分の気持ちが悪くなってくるでしょ
そうすると今私は楽しい
今私は幸せ 今私は安穏
今私は安らぎを感じている
と聞いてください これ呪文です
聞いたらないとチェック入るんです
行為をしたくなった時も同じチェックを入れる
はい これで一応 この試験で落第したならば
3番目の項目に入ります
3番目は こちらは 3番目の行なんですね
感情に先にチェック入れちゃうと感情が消えるんですよ
面白いんですよ これって楽しくない？幸福じゃない
これ私の宿題は？私の課題は幸福に生きることでしょうにと
と知ってるんだから 自動的にあの怒り
憎しみが消えるんです
その場合 でもそこでうまくいかなかったならば
もう行為始めているんです
気持ち悪くなった相手が言ったことに
相手に一言葉言いたくなってるでしょ
一言葉ではなくて 結構たくさん言葉を言いたくなっているんです
その時もこの言葉を言う
言うと 私がいい気分になるのかと
人にきつい言葉をかけて
人を悪い気持ちにさせて
気分がよろしいですか？と
で チェック入れる 行為をする時もチェックを入れる
それでもうまくいかなかった
やっぱり喋り出しちゃった
その時も今私が楽しいかとチェック入れてください
それからやって終わってからもチェックを入れてください
これで完全安全生き方が成り立つんです
いとも簡単な方法で ただチェック入れるだけ
それやってると 1 日でうまくいかないよ
で 実践してみるんです
毎日 そうするとどんどん理性も知恵も現れてきて
どんどん幸せになっちゃって
どんどん穏やかになっちゃって
どんどん幸福になりまして
結構うまくいきます 好転します
それで道が現れます 前のページで生き方をページの生き方をしてみると
衝動が徐々に現れてきます
なんで徐々にとか言ったのは
この原始脳の問題あるんだからなんです
行為と感情の関係がわかるようになります
怒りだったらこのこのことをするんだ
嫉妬だったらこのこのことをするんだ
憎しみだったらこういうことをするんだ
落ち込みだったらこういうことをするんだと
行為と感情の関係がわかってきます
どのような感情がどのような行為を引き起こすのかとも発見します
例えば怒りができたら美味しいご飯作って人を接待するとは成り立ちませんね
よくわかりますよ 恨みが出たら
その人にお金あげて助けてあげるということはありえないんですね
それでどんな行為 どんな感情がどんな行為をするのかと
例えば相手のことを心配しちゃうと
自分がこういうこういう行為をする
相手のことを恨むと 自分がこういうこういうことをする
と 行為と感情の関係 いわゆる煩悩と行為
行為の関係が見えてくる
これは仏教的に言えばすごい智慧なんですよ
正しい行為によって自分がどのように幸福になっているのかも理解します
例えば 人のことを心配するようになる
哀れむようになる そうするとなんか私は幸せですかと
幸せなんです 人のことも心配するならば
本人が幸せを感じているんです
人を助けたい気持ちになっていると
もうとっくに自分が幸せを感じているんです
チェック入れてください
この気持ちで私は幸せですかと OK
幸せですと この気持ちでいる
私は安穏でしょう  OK
安穏ですとチェック入ります
そういうことで 正しい行為はなんぞやと自分でわかるんです
ブッダに読む必要もなくなっちゃうし
宗教を読む必要もなくなっちゃうし
ただ自分で発見する これはいいこと
これはいいこと これは悪いこと
すごい智慧でしょ 自分自身で善悪行為を知っていると
自分の行為でも 行為で他も幸福になるのだと発見します
すごいこと発見 自分のこの幸せになる行為
私が安穏になりたいんだからやっているだけ
私が幸福になりたいからやっているだけなんですけど
しかし このことで私だけではなくて
他の人々も幸せになっているんだとびっくりします
自分が幸せになるんだと課題を変えちゃうと
生きる目的を変えちゃうと
物の見事に自分だけじゃなくて周りも幸せになっている
そうするとしっかりと自信がついてくるんです
無知のせいで無常たる現象に執着していたことも
もっと進んで私は生きていきたいということは昔思っていたんだけどね
でもバカバカらしいでしたね
あれは と すべて無常ね
すべて無常なのに よくもバカで執着したもんだなとわかるんです
執着が不幸を司だっていたことも
なんで私は不幸になったのか
これ 執着の問題でしたと
例えば 仕事に収入に執着すると
ライバル会社のシステムハッキングします
執着なんです それで全てなくなってしまいます
だから あ 不幸を作ったのは執着だとわかるんです
執着はもともと成り立たないことも発見します
そういうことをじわじわと発見していくのです
執着は成り立ちません
例えば 私はここに立っているのは短い時間
無常だから出て行かなくちゃいけない
私はこれ マイクロフォンだな
あれこれ好きだなとか愛着を作ったっても
バカ以外何でもないでしょ
だから自分の若さに健康にあれにこれに執着したっても
もうバカ以外何でもない
いろんなのは変化するんだから
だから執着は捨てなさいではないんです
仏教では 智慧が現れると執着は成り立たないとわかるんです
それがわかりやすく執着を捨てまったと言うんです
執着を減らす生き方をすることで
幸福に生きられることも
執着を捨てることで究極の幸福に達するのだということも智慧で発見します
たった単純なプログラムで解脱に達するまで道が現れてきます
全然問題ないんです ただ
存在欲と恐怖感で生きることをやめましょう
それだけ その代わりに幸福を目的にしてください
苦を避けることを目的にしてください
決して悪くないでしょう
幸福に生きたって罰が当たるわけないでしょう
ただ それで全て道が現れてきます
悟りに解脱に涅槃に達するまで
道がどんどんどんどん
現れてきます はい これで今日のテーマは終わりですけど
また付属的ないくつかのテーマ説明します
癖って何ですか？と 繰り返し行ったことで大脳に回路が
このかっこの中の回路でしょう
正しいのができている
配線ができちゃうんですね
そうすると いとも簡単にこれが行動してやっちゃいます
それで何か我々は繰り返しするんですよ
小さい時から 小さい時から繰り返し何かやったっても
それは原始脳でやってるでしょ
子供には別に頭ができてないんだから
物事の判断できないんだから
これはやがて癖になってやめられなくなるんです
原始脳が一定の感情で大脳を刺激すると
適した回路 間違ってますけど
回路が出来上がります
漢字間違ってます 電気に使う回路ですね
そこで原始脳も貪瞋痴
存在欲なんですけど それいろいろ強弱働き方
個人によって違います
ですから感情が人によって違います
だからある一定の感情がピッピッと大脳に刺激を入れちゃうと
子供の時からも大脳で回路が現れてしまいます
それに反応する回路 それに対する行為も起きてしまいます
しかし 悪い癖は苦労してでも直すべきです
だから 癖だから別に判断するとか何とか起きてないんだけど
考えてやってるわけじゃないんだからね
でも悪い癖は苦労してでもやめた方がいいんです
方法は良い習慣を繰り返して起こすことで
脳に新たな回路を作ることです
で これで脳って面白いんですよ
かなり積極的に動くんです
例えば悪い癖がある 脳に回路ができちゃって
脳細胞を使っているんです
それでそこを直すために
毎回毎日毎日何回も訓練すると
あれも似てるでしょ そちらに新しい回路が出てくるんです
同じ場所で現れるんです
現れると元の回路は解除するんです
解除してこの細胞を使っちゃうんです
だから綺麗になくなるんです
例えば嘘をつく癖があると
嘘をつかない癖を作る場合は同じ場所を使うんです
脳の中で ですから悪い癖を直すと
綺麗に回路が配線壊れちゃって
新しい配線が回路が現れている
これってコンセントの穴が一つしかない場合は
一つ電気製品使っていて
これじゃなくて別なもの使いたくなっちゃうと
あれ外さなくちゃあかんでしょ
外して挿す そんな感じですね
脳の中で 人に過去世から持っている癖もあります
これは結構 難しいんです
はい 付属的にまた学ぶことがありまして
これがもう終わり 世を守る慚愧
慚愧でしたっけ 慚愧でした
世っていうのは世の中
人々を守ってくれる項目 2つあります 1
仏教用語でヒリと言うんですね
これ慚愧の慚ですね 悪行為を恥じる気持ちです
悪いことは恥じるのは恥ずかしいと
人間が面白い原始脳で生きているのに
どこかで悪行為を恥じるという気持ちもあるんです
良い意味のプライドですね
それは自分を大事にする気持ち
それはヒリと言うんです
2番目はおたっぷと言うんです
これ 日本語になると慚愧とあまり短すぎです
だからパーリ語ではこれ大事な単語だから
ヒリオタップとちょっと長いフレーズにしているんです
喜とは悪行為を怖がる気持ちです
悪行為をすると悪い結果になる
不幸になる 罰を受けることになるという気持ちです
怖いと感じることです
良い意味の怯えです だから良い意味のプライドがありまして
良い意味の怯えがあるんです
我々にも微かにあるんです
両方合わせると正しく生きることができます
だからお釈迦様の完璧なプログラム嫌なら慚愧ぐらい守ってみてください
やるやめる問題はなくなっちゃいます
自動的に悪いことをやめる
良いことはする 次 なぜやめられない？というテーマをします
癖になっているから 判断機能が先入観に変わっているんです
何か癖になると 判断しないで行動するということを思っているでしょう
違います 癖になった場合はもう判断とっくに決まっているんです
有罪か無罪かと それは先入観でプレジュディスなんですね
もうもうとっくに判断している
調べていないんです ただそれだけ
だから判断があるんです
ただ 判断は前もって決めていただけ
その場合はやめられる
やめる時間ないんです
感情が起きた もうやっちゃった
やりなさいという判断は
初めからもうもうOKになっているんです
五感の刺激に依存している場合も同じなんです
五感というのは眼耳鼻舌身でしょ
刺激に依存して楽しいと
例えばタバコをやめられない
なぜ あれ美味しいんだから
五感の刺激 これに依存しているんです
悪いとわかっていても
大脳が依存症にかかっています
大脳で一部これ悪いとわかってますけど
何かしら大脳に依存症があります
いわゆるすごい弱い大脳
頭がすごく弱い 悪い 何かしらの依存症がある
そうするとやめられなくなっちゃうんです
原始脳を中心にして生きている
理性客観性を大事にしない
これは結構ありますよ
私たちは感情だけで 喜怒哀楽だけで生きているんですね
だからやめられないでしょうに
いくら悪いと言っても
それは原始脳の中心 いわゆる獣の指導で
獣に支配されて生きているんです
まあどうしようもないんです
もう一つ これ優しい理由なんですけど
理解が足らない いわゆるまだわかってない
あなたは ということで納得していない
悪いと納得したらやめているんです
もう 理解と納得というのはほぼ同じものだからね
悪感情で妄想することは依存症になっています
もう一つ 妄想ばっかり
妄想依存症 思考依存ではなくて
妄想 妄想というのは悪感情です
これやっちゃうと病気になるんです
だから妄想依存症の方々
ずっと妄想している方々にも
良いことをすることもできないし
悪いことはやめられないし
これデータがたくさんありますけど
まあそこでそんなもんにします
次 なぜやめられるというテーマを考えてみましょう
はい これやめられないことを説明しました
やめられる なぜ？懺悔を実践する
懺悔を実践すればもう悪いことはやめちゃいますよ
問題ないんです 苦労して大脳で理解する
納得する 頑張って勉強して
考えて苦労して 頭でしっかり理解する
しっかり納得する そうすると自動的にもうやめているんです
それによって原始脳の刺激は正しくないとわかるんです
頭で理解すると 原始脳が間違っていたんだとわかるんです
これでいっときは簡単にやめられます
誘惑に負けない自己責任を持つ人間になる
もし私たちはこんな誘惑に負けるわけないでしょうと
私は自分で選んだんです
あなたの誘惑には乗りませんと
自己責任を持つ人間になると
やめることは簡単にできます
挑戦することが楽しいと思う人間になる
これでやめることっていうのは三日坊主になっちゃうでしょ
あれ 挑戦が楽しくないね
だから何かに挑戦する
それが楽しいと やってみることは楽しいんだと思っちゃうと
またやめられることはできます
次のテーマは幸福を理解する
1生命は貪瞋痴の衝動で
いわゆる原始脳の刺激で生きているんです
やむを得ず 存在欲と恐怖感の奴隷になっているが
決して感情は幸福 安らぎ
安穏を与えてくれません
こういうふうに理解しておいてほしい
原始脳は一度たりとも安穏を与えてくれません
生きていきたいだけだから
恐怖感だけだから 安らぎはないんです
しかし今私はやむを得ず原始脳の獣の脳の奴隷なんです
だからそれを理解するんです
これでは幸福になりませんと
貪瞋痴を制御して理性で生きるならば
楽に生きられるし 幸福を感じることもできます
だから貪瞋痴を制御する
理性で生きる そうすると楽だ
生きることは楽だとわかるんです
楽しいんだ 幸せだとわかってくるんです
貪瞋痴の感情を滅尽することが真の幸福です
それが理解しておけば
永遠の天国ではなくて
極楽道で往生することでもなく
貪瞋痴なくすことが幸福であると
究極の幸福であると理解しておけばまあ大丈夫です
それで本当はやめるやめないではなくて
そのステップからも脱出してほしいんです
やめるやめないことに引っかかるのもエゴの感情です
必要なのは不幸と苦しみを作り出す原始脳の支配を破って
客観性と理性で働ける大脳に支配権を与えることです
やめるやめないかでは問題じゃありません
これは脳で言えば脳の開発で
仏教で言えば心の開発で
必要なのはそれです 心の革命
仏教的に言えば 煩悩をなくして智慧を開発することです
必要なのはそれですよ
何何かやっているか 何何かやっていないか
そんなのはどうでもいい
俗世間的な話でしょ 成功者にとっては
行為は善でも悪でもない
ただの行為です はい このスライドを書いたのは
世の中で道徳を自慢する人々がいるんです
私は肉魚食べません 私はある人がいるんでば
もう40年間もね 朝起きて冷たい水をね
100個バケツで体にかけるんだと
夏であろうが冬であろうが
てますよと 普通の店 えらい自慢です
で 奥さんもね まあアホなことやっててやめた方がいいと
奥さんが賢い賢かったんだけどね
私は言わなかったんだ
お前アホやと だからその人はまあ仏教にも興味ないし
そういう変ななんか新興宗教に興味あるんだけど
そういう変なものにあっても原始脳から脱出できない
菜食主義自慢する人はいるし
まあ月一回断食しているんだと自慢する人もいるし
インドではジャイナ教ではね
裸でいることを自慢する人もいるし
いろいろ儀式 儀礼 しきたり
引っかかるんですよ あんなのはエゴなんです
あんなのはエゴなんです
だから当然嘘をついてはいけませんし
殺生してはいけませんし
だからといって殺生自慢っていうのはね
悪くはないかもしれませんだけど
エゴ絡んではいけません
仏教的に殺生しないことにする
酒飲めないことにする
それは私は酒飲んでないよと
仏教徒だからと自慢するのは構わないんだけど
気をつけてほしい あれはエゴになったらもう良くないんです
原始脳はそのままになっちゃうんです
理性で なんであんた酒飲まないんか
酒飲んだらこういうこういう悪いことになるし
頭がおかしくなるし 飲まない方が健康で楽しいしね
だから私は酒を飲まないこと
飲まないことを喜んでますよと
そちらで理性が得てるんです
はい そういうことで あの
やめるやめないという
この 2 項目が世の中で人間の足かせにもなってます
ただ その項目で人間がチョイスしないことにもなってるんです
獣のレベルから だから私はやめるやめないではなく
脱出であると この最後のスライドを書いたんです
だからポイントは原始脳を抑えて大脳に支配権を上げる
あるいは感情をすべてなくしちゃって知恵で生きる
どちらかなんです はい
話は以上です では どうもありがとうございます
質問などあったら時間はあります
それではこれから質疑応答の時間としたいと思います
時間が今 8時 20分頃なので 40
分ほど時間があります
今日のお話に関して もしご質問などあればいらっしゃいましたら挙手していただけますでしょうか
マイク回します  たくさん言えないから 2つだけお伺いします
今日は原始脳という言葉が最初に出てきたんですけど
日本では割と本能という言い方ですけど
本能と原始脳の関係は一緒なのか違うのか
はい 一緒です  そうですか
はい もう一つですね 結局
自分が幸福になると他人も幸福になる
その言い方はですね 日本では情けは人のための愛と
要するに自分のためにやってるんだということで
ある意味ではわかるんですけれど
仏教の中で言いますと
大乗仏教と小乗仏教というか
南方と北方仏教の違いが何だというと
要するに南方仏教は自分が解脱する為に解脱するために
自分のためだけやっているような言い方を大乗はするんですけれど
そこが何て言うんですかね
他人の幸福のためにやるんだという考え方は
結局自分の幸福のためにやるんだから
そっちの方が先なんだということなんですね
そこら辺がちょっと  例えば大乗仏教のその考えを作った人々は仏教ではなくてね
これインドで出来上がった考えですからね
仏教を破壊するためにね
修行する人々を修行から修行をやめさせるために作った
この破壊的な考えですね
大乗に入っていっているのはね
嘘を言ってるんですよ
人間が 自分のことを置いておいて
他人のことって これありえない話で
誰もやったことはないしね
だから科学知らないんですね
心理学知らないんですね
心にはこの自分のためがなければ働かないんです
例えばお母さんが子供のためなら死んでもいいやと言ってる話があるでしょ
お母さんがじゃあ自分のためではなくじゃないんですよ
お母さんがもう最高に幸せですよ
子供が生まれて 子供の面倒を見ることで楽しくて楽しくて
もうどうしようもない状態なんです
だからやってるんです
時々オキシトシンという幸福物質が生まれない場合は
子供を殺したりもしますからね
ですから まあこれはこの心理学知らないだけの話で
あまり気にする必要はないと思います
で それから大乗仏教は人のために頑張っていると
自分のためではないんだと言って
自分たちが堕落した 大乗世界は人のためにやったことは何もない
テーラワーダ仏教では
自分の心清らかなことをすることで
自分が真剣真面目に仏教を学ぶことで周りも幸せになるんだと
だからテーラワーダ世界では結構人は助かってます
だから ある大学の教授が私に同じ質問を出したんで
あなた方の場合はね あの
自分の利益しか考えないでしょうと
したら 私は先生 現実的に見ましょうかと
一般人がどうしても必須だと思っているのは大乗仏教あるいはテーラワーダ仏教ですか？と
仏教がなかったら困りますよと心配しているのはどちらですか？と
2500年も命かけて仏教を守ってくれたのはどんな国ですか？と
だから 客観的な社会的なデータを見ると
テーラワーダの世界の人々にとっては
仏教がなくなったら大変なことになるんです
日本の社会では 仏教が人が死んじゃったら
うちはどんな宗教でしょうと
お寺でぱっかしたことだったけどでしょ
葬式で終わってるんだから
日常生活に何の関係もないんです
だから結局はデータを見ると間違ってるってことはあったりするんですね
まあそんな話は別にあんまり面白くないんだから
そこら辺でやめますが
論理的というかね やっぱり自分が
例えば人を助ける それで自分が楽しいでしょうね
助けるたびに自分が不幸になるんだったら
それは人らしくしませんよ
心はすごく安らぎを安らぎを感じるんです
例えば 人は自分を頼りにしている
面倒くさいんですよ 頼りにしていると
面倒くさいんだけど 自分が生き生きしているんです
人が自分を頼りにしてるんだと
自分に頼っているんだよと
ふざけてる場合じゃないんだ
結局は自分には生きる勇気が与えているんです
そういうことで 自利他利っていうのは区別不可能です
区別した時点で間違ってます
はい 他にあのご質問あると
はい 質問させていただきます
やめたいことはやめれるということで
やめたいと私は思ってるんですけども
仕事で失敗した時に日本人なんか多いんですけど
とにかく謝る すみません
すみません ごめんなさい
申し訳ないです もしくはすぐ弁明をし始める
いや そんなそうじゃなかったんですよ
いや そうじゃないんですよ
でもそういった行為というのはやめた方がよろしいんでしょうか
仏教的には  どういった行為？すいません
謝るとかですね とにかく謝るとか
謝って逃げる 逃げられると思ったらすごい詐欺師で失敗したら謝るのは普通でしょうしね
だから仕事の失敗っていうのは
これはもう避けられませんね
失敗するっていうことは自然法則ですよ
これはもうどうしようもないんで
だから仏教的にやればものすごく失敗少なくはなるんです
だから私の場合も結構失敗といえばかなり少ないと思いますけど
ゼロではないんです ゼロではないで
結構あるんです だからその場合は素直にすいません
でいいんです はい  はい
その他の方 あ いや 前 えーと
貴重なお話ありがとうございました
今日のお話の中で存在欲
存在欲 捨てる それから恐怖感捨てるというお話がありますけども
自分の心掛けとしてはよくわかるんですけども
職場で例えば上司がですね
存在欲の塊で自分を大きく見せようと人にエゴ的な人とかですね
あるいは家庭でも配偶者
奥さんがそうであったり
逆に旦那さんがそうであったりとか
要は逃げられない関係ですね
そういう避けられない関係の時に
そういう人に対してはどういう接し方をしたらいいか
適した方法 方法があるかどうかですね
それをお聞きしたいんです
あの人がこの感染度が高い病気になったら
我々はどうする？うつしてもらう
その病気はうつしてもらわないね
看病はする 病院にお見舞いに行く
お金がないと言ったらお金もあげる
もうやるべきことは全部やりますけど
自分も感染していただきますということはありえないんですね
だからブッダの道をわかるのはほんのわずかな人間なんですよ
世の中で我々は感情で
存在欲と恐怖感で生きている人間の中で生きていなくちゃいけないんですね
だから自分がそれで感染しないようにしなくてはいけない
1 2番目は 例えば上司であろうか
家の奥様であろうか 見栄を張ったり
大きく見せたりすることで
この方々は結構失敗しているんですよ
うまくいってないんです
幸福を感じてないんです
だから私たちにできることは
ちょびちょびでも幸福を感じるようにしてあげる
なんとなくの感染しないようにね
例えばね ああいう方々は褒めてほしいんですね
だから褒めてあげる 人を褒めることはインチキであったらね
ちょっと仏教的に良くないんだから
何かいいことを見つけて
これいいですねとかね
すごいよくできたねとかね
そういう風に奥様の場合でもね
もう何かしら褒めてあげる
で 感謝する癖をつく 自分がね
今日は朝ご飯美味しいです
ありがとうございますとかね
いや それはまあ形式的にありがとうねとかね
美味しかったよとかね
そんな風に何か何か投げ捨てた言葉でいいんです
それはよく通じるんです
卵焼きであ 今日よくよく焼いてます
焼かれてますとかね これってまあ毎日ですから
あんた腕がいいですよ
なんとか言う 上司の場合もそういう何なんとか何とか言うようにして
人々にこのちょびっとちょびっと幸せを感じさせる
幸せを感じた瞬間で その人の自我がちょっと弱くなるんです
で そういう風に態度を取るしかないんです
で 世間の病気が私は喜んで感染していただくということは
あまり理性的な生き方ではないです
はい 以上です  はい 他の方
欲欲望についての質問なんですが
心理学でマズローの欲望の段階みたいな理論がありまして
具体的にはその段階が何かはすぐに思い出せないんですけども
基本的な安全の欲求から始まって
自己承認の欲求があって
それから自己表現の欲求があって
最後になんかマズローちゃんが欲求につながるみたいな
その下の部分の欲求が満たされないと次の段階に行けないみたいな
そんなふうな理論があるんですけども
そうするとそれは欲望を肯定するような理論ではあるんですけど
そういうのを仏教的にこういった理論についてどうお考えになられますか？ 私はそういう段階のことは知りませんですから
そう解説するのはね 失礼と思いますね
まあ仏教の場合は欲の段階といえばね
1500煩悩あるでしょ
1500煩悩の 3分の1は欲ですからね
だから 500種類がありましてね
で 段階的に仏教 あれは正直に私から見ればすごい幼稚的な分析ですね
本物はわかってないんで
欲望はいらんということをわかってないんですよ
心理学ではそれはわかってないんです
欲望は危険であると これは存在欲でしょう
基本的にはね だから存在欲は無意味であると
無神論者のね 道化さんも言ってるんだからね
ただ遺伝子がわがままで勝手に動いてるだけでしょうと
こんなのはと だからこの存在欲は危険であるということは
仏教だけの話でね 存在欲を捨てたらどうなるのかと
俗世間では考えられませんよ
えっ 存在欲を捨てたらって怖くなるんです
だから心理学のああいう話は
仏教から見れば幼稚な話で
問題は把握していないだけなんですね
仏教的な段階っていうのは
一番軽い段階から言えば五欲
我々は眼耳鼻舌身から刺激を得たい
美しいものを見て 香りを嗅いで
美味しい味を味わって
脳に刺激を与えたい だからといって
問題は食べないでいるわけにはいきませんね
だから食べることはやめられませんし
音を聞くこともやめられませんだけど
その場合は食べたい気持ちは存在欲なんですね
だから食べたい気持ちはなかなか肉体ある限りは残るんだけど
まあ肉体を維持するために食べてみますということは
我々修行者がやっているんです
これ 美味しいんだから食べますということは全くないんです
これ 珍しい食べ物だから食べてみますはないんです
で 命を繋げたい 壊れたら困ります
だから食べるっていう
だからそこで基本的な存在欲というところあるんですね
それから次の欲っていうのは妄想
そうですね で いろんなことを妄想して妄想して脳を動かしちゃうんですね
心を動かしちゃうんですね
それで心にエネルギーが生まれて生まれて
業と業じゃなくて 参加衝動というんですけど
エネルギーが溜めるんですね
溜めて溜めて輪廻転生するまで行っちゃうんですね
それも欲で 基本的には存在欲
またお釈迦様が欲はカーマタンナ
ババタンナ イバタンナと 3つに分けてますね
カーマタンナは五欲で
ババタンナは存在欲で
ヴィババタンナっていうのは
この恐怖感 存在欲を支えてくれないものは破壊してやるぞというね
いう 3つなんですね  5つはありません
はい 以上です  今日はどうもありがとうございました
貴重なお話を 私がちょっと質問したいのはですね
存在欲と恐怖心という
両方とも先生のお話ではあまり好ましくないものというふうな説明があったんですけども
例えばですね 若い人では
例えばオリンピックとか
そういうところで金メダルを取りたいという人にとっては
自分の存在を世界に知らしめたいとか
そのスポーツ界で 1位になりたいとか
そういう存在欲から来てると思うんですね
それからまた 例えば元巨人の王選手なんかは
毎回ホームランを打つたびに
いつか打てなくなるんじゃないかという恐怖心からね
毎晩バットを何百回も振ったという逸話があるんですけども
そういうことを存在欲とか恐怖心を一つの動機にしてね
その人が頑張って精進していくということについての場合における
その存在欲とか動機というのは
やっぱり仏教的には正しくないものということになるんでしょうか
そこをちょっと説明いただきたいんですけども
だからそれは王さんとかね
オリンピック選手だけじゃなくて
誰にだってやってることでしょうに
誰だって一般人が存在欲と恐怖感で生きているんです
原始脳の衝動で生きているんです
それはどれぐらい頑張るかというだけの話で
だから うまくいくかいかないかはわからないです
スポーツ選手が能力あれば頑張るのは構わないんだけど
だからといってうまくいくかいけるかわからないし
メダルを取れるか取れないかわからないし
だから王さんにしたっても
ホームランを打てるか打てないかわからないしね
だからまあ それによってさらに不安が出てくるんですよ
その不安というのはイチローさんにもあります
しかし そういう方々は
世界に名前を知らせて知られてね
すごい人間になったということではなくて
この自分が歩んだ険しい道を自己観察すると
いくらかまともな人間になり得る可能性もありますね
ね まあ仏教的に言えば
この別にいい悪い話じゃなくて
誰でもやってることでしょ
だから世にない課題 皆様に提案するんです
幸福を目指しなさいと
だから世に存在しないんです
ブッダのメッセージは
世界で存在しないんです
これはオリンピック選手と長さんに限ったものじゃないんです
誰だって恐怖感と存在欲を生かしちゃう
これはうまく怪我しないで生かせる人もいるし
怪我して失敗する人もいるし
では王さんのような方々
まあそれで生きている間はまあ認められて生きるだけでしょう
それで年取って死んでしまいますね
だから私はアメリカオリンピックの開会式見たんだけど
あの最後にかなね あの聖火台というんですかね
あれは 何が正解かわかりませんだけど
あれ最後に最後か真ん中かわからないんだけど
一応試合場でキャシースクレイグ
モハメド・アリ世界王者でしたから
ボクシングでね で カレーに彼が持っていくんですね
ボクシングで世界王者でしたけど
歩けないんですよ あのトーチを取れないんです
で パーキンソンだとは思いますけど
かなり体が壊れちゃって
だからそんなもんなんですね
だから ...いくらかお金が入ったかもしれませんだけど
別にお金がなくても我々も私も生きてますけどね
だからね そんなに高く評価するべきものかっていうこと問題なんですね
ただ まあ皆様 生命はみんな動物もみんな恐怖感と存在欲で生きているんです
獣の衝動で生きているんです
それはもう断言的な 断言的というか
真理の話なんです 悪行為しているかしないかという悪いことかっていう話ではないんですね
悪いといいと言っている場合じゃない
いいことではないんです
いわゆる選ぶべき道ではないというかね
もっと超越した道を選ぶならば
まあ幸福を目指しなさいなんです
人は自由です 何のどんな道を選んでもね
まあそんな程度の答えしかできません
はい  ありがとうございます
科学的データに基づいて客観的に物事を判断するという点での質問なんですけど
例えば例えばなんですけど
地球が温暖化している
そのことについて科学的に自分で調べたりとかするときに
必ず問題になるのは いろんな本があって
例えば科学者が書いた本なんですけど
実は温暖化なんてしてないよとか
あと人間の活動が その二酸化炭素が温暖化に直接結びついてないだとか
もしくは実は地球は寒冷化してるんだとか
いろんな科学のデータが溢れてて
どの本を読むかによってちょっと視点が変わってきちゃって
何が正しい答えだかっていうことがわからなくなってしまうんですが
そういった科学的な客観的なデータに基づいて判断するという上でのコツとか
あの いろんな情報が溢れているこの世の中で
正しいデータを掴むにはどうしたらいいかということを教えていただけたらと思います
うーん まあ私はこの科学的という場合は
この世の中にある科学という物理科学のことを考えてないんです
サイエンティフィックなんです
私は考えているのは これは我々インド文化系の言葉を使う我々は日常茶飯事に使う単語なんです
今はなんかある一定の学問が自分だけ科学やって言ってますけど
私たちの言語の科学に使う単語っていうのは
仏教にも使うし ごく日常茶飯事に使うんです
それで質問の内容なんですけど
温暖化している していないという話はね
ダムを作るべきかやめるべきかとかね
羽田空港を開発するべきかやめるべきかっていって
ごちゃごちゃどちらもそれぞれ自分の都合でデータを持って言ってるだけで当てにならないんですね
結局は科学者も存在欲と恐怖感で科学をやってるんだから
そんなに信頼性はないんです
例えばアメリカが世界は核兵器を持つべきではありません
すごい厳しいんですね
しかし 自分たちは持つべき
バカバカらしい話ですけど
アメリカがリーダーシップ取って世界から核兵器なくそうと思っちゃうと
そこでアメリカ イギリス
ソ連 そういうロシアやそういう国々も解除するでしょうに
そうするとイランとかどんな誰かさんがね
核兵器を作ろうと思ったっても潰してやることできるでしょうに
なんだこりゃと 世界的な決まりに反対でしょう
だから自分の都合で自分の存在欲と恐怖感でしか物事を見てないんですよ
だから科学と言ったっても
そういう曖昧中途半端なことというのはいくらでもあります
だから誰かから金入るんだったら
まあその金入れた研究費を出した会社の希望に合わせるんですね
研究データを だからそんな世の中ですよ
我々生きているのは だから私の考えは
このあまりにも乗らないというね
で 相手が人格者であるならば
まあ問題はありません
そうでもないんですね
最近日本で亡くなられた宇沢なんとかという経済学者がいたんですね
何でした名前は忘れた
え？え？え？宇沢弘文さん
はい あの方は素晴らしい人格者で
私ももう安寧の思いで亡くなってから知ったんだからね
経済学間違ってるんだよと
だから世界を逆に騙されちゃったんですね
でも私から見れば完璧な経済学者なんですね
経済学っていうのは 人はみんないかに幸福にすることであると
利益の問題ではありませんと
だからそういうふうな珍しい人格者が何か言うならば
それはそのまま受け取った方が世のため自分のためになります
でも社会はそういう人々をバッシングして追い出しますね
アメリカは彼 アメリカにいた人なんですけど
もう全く認めない 競争が正しいと
弱肉強食 競争が正しいと
だから向こうは向こうの利益でそう考えているんだと
だから世の中でまともな経済学もまともな科学も何も存在しないんですね
困ったもんですよ だから私たちは個人で何ができるのかということを考えることからね
始めればいいんじゃないかなと
うん まあ例えば温暖化
温暖化と言ったっても
じゃあオゾン層がなくなってるんだとかね
だからあちらこちらいっぱい緑を作っちゃえば
至る所で緑を作る ビルの壁も屋根もどこでもコケでもいいんですからね
こんないろんな変な色鮮やかな自然破壊的なビルではなくて
もう緑のある世界を作っちゃうと
いっぱい酸素を作るでしょ
それは各個人個人でやらなくちゃいけない
それでその問題は解決する
いくらでいくら回したっても
そんなに大きな問題にならない
そこで私たちは電気を使うことにケチをつけるんだけど
ロケットを飛ばすことやら
そういうのに何も言いません
だから自分の都合で喋ってるだけの世界なんですね
そういうわけで 科学者もただの人間であると
存在欲と恐怖感で研究しているんだと
ですから もう誤りの誤った判断はあり得るんだと言って
客観的に自分たちで調べるしかないと思います
聖書のように読んで理解する本というのはないんです
例えば 私は宗教反対的な立場を取っているんだから
アメリカで出している本の中で道元さんの本が好きなんですね
彼の本はほとんど読んでいるとは思います
が 完璧に乗ってるわけじゃないんです
彼が間違いを知ってます
だから存在欲から逃げてないんですね
アルジャジーラというテレビ局に入って
彼のもうすごいある動画とはディスカッションになりましたけど
イスラムの方ですごい立派な人が質問しましたけど
やっぱり道元さんにはビシッと答えられないんですね
この人えらい頭がいい人なのに
なんでこの simpleなこの質問に答えられないのかとそう思ったんだけどね
だからこの人間っていうのはね
だから完全に信頼できるものは誰も言ってないんです
そこら辺 我々は各自で気をつけるしかないでしょうね
はい 以上です  ありがとうございます
癖のところが非常に質問があるんですが
悪い習慣で大脳にインストールされたものを良い習慣でリセットするということだったんですが
その後 過去世の癖というお話が出ました
過去世の癖っていうのは
過去世から大脳にインストールされるものなんですか？それともその家族
先祖代々から受け継がれるようなものが
子供の時に育って教え込まれてインストールされるようなものなんですか？ 先祖代々ではないんです
輪廻転生すると 自分の心にあったプログラムが原始脳にインストールするんですね
こちらで だから OS できちゃうんですね
原始脳に この OS の場合は
過去世の何かちょっと何かあったらそこ入ってしまうんですね
それには仏教の場合でも
あんまり何も言ってないんですね
なんか難しいんですね
あの それっての そんなに癖っていうのは全てなくす必要はないんです
で この悪い癖だったら直してほしいだけの話で
癖は全部直す必要はないんです
で 癖というのはどうったことないものだからね
考えればね 言葉を使う時も癖があってね
で 私にも言葉を使う場合は
先に言うべきことと後回しにしちゃうんですね
あれは自分の言語と英語の癖かもしれませんね
日本語では主語と目的語と言いたいことは最後に言わなくちゃいけないんだけど
私はもうそれ先に言っちゃうんですね
で 皆様の頭がちょこっとこんがらがっちゃうんですね
で 直したいと思ってはいるんだけど
なかなか直れないんですね
これっていうのは そういう風にいろんな
まあそんなに直らなくていい癖っていうのはあるんです
はい 一つはエピソードを言います
過去世の癖としてね 仏教の物語の中では結構入ってます
過去世の癖ということで
結論は放っておきましょうと
一つは あるお坊さんが
誰と喋ってもすごいしつこい
このキリストというか
すごい失礼な言葉を使うんですね
で パーリ語だから この人を呼ぶ場合は
あなたあなた様とか言うべき時
チャンダラという言葉を使う
チャンダラっていうのは奴隷
不可触という意味なんですね
だからバラモン人と喋るところで
この奴隷が何言ったんですかと言っちゃうと
人によってあの水を欲しくて
え？奴隷そちらちょっと水をいっぱい持ってきてくださいと
こんなこと言うの人に対して
日本語ではそんなすごいびっくりするほどの言葉がないですからね
お前とかてめえとかってそんな程度ですね
それはそんなに卑猥な言葉ではないんですからね
それでみんななんだこの人
愛語っていうのは仏教の決まりでしょうにと
これ戒律でしょうにと
お釈迦様さえ人を非難侮辱する単語は決して使わないのに
なんだこのお坊さんはと
すごい非難が起きたところで
お釈迦様の答えは放っておきなさいと
あの人は悟っている阿羅漢ですよと
でもこの癖が直らないんだと
なぜかというと この人は過去世で何回も 500回
何回もかなりの残酷なカーストで生まれて
乱暴にメスかいに言葉使ってきたんだと
だからその言葉使い これが本人にとってはもう原始脳に入っちゃって
それがもう回路できちゃって
本人が悪意は全くないんです
だからお釈迦様は放っとけということで
放っておくことにしたんですね
もう一つエピソードがありまして
ある信者さんがお坊さんたちにお布施をと家に連れていくんですね
それで このお坊さんたちが阿羅漢であると思っていたんです
そこでこの田んぼから家に行かなくちゃいけないんですね
田んぼで結構水たまりがあったんですね
ちょっと幅があって みんなどうしようもなく水に入って
そのまま歩いて行ったんですね
一人のまあ ただ歳を取っていたお坊さんなんで
なんのことなくビシッと飛んだんですよ
向こう側に いとも簡単に
結構距離もあったのに
この信者さんががくっと落ち込んじゃったんで
阿羅漢だと思ってたのに
ただのギギでしょうと
落ち込んじゃって 自分の悩みをお釈迦様に言ったんですね
そうしたら お釈迦様 あのね
あのお坊さんたちの中で
あの人が大阿羅漢ですよと
ではあれは何やと これが過去の癖やと
この人はね あの人はもうそんな水たまりだったらもう飛ぶでしょうにと
で 過去生でこういうこういう生き方をしていたんだと
そういうふうな過去生っていうのは先祖代々ではない
それしっかりしてください
自分の過去生なんですね
で 原始脳に原始脳がこの世のものですよ
だから原始脳論は仏教的じゃないんです
あれはただの私は科学者からパクった話で喋ってるだけで
脳が出来上がると心が入り込みますから
だからそこで脳にプログラムを作ってしまうんですね
まあ悪い癖だけね やめるようにしましょう
他の癖は人にバレバレであってもしょうがないんです
以上です  ありがとうございました
また今田さん えっと 質問はですね
ちょっと関係があるかわからないのですが
子供を産むことと存在意義と存在欲
この関連性はあるんでしょうか？それと僕はあるスッタを勉強したんですが
クガーパカスッタの中で子供を作ることをに関しては一生懸命助けなくてもいいと
女性になった人も一生懸命助けなくてもいいよというのがあったんですけども
そのちょっと理解ができなかったので
そこを聞いていただければと
私も理解してなかったんです
はっきり聞こえなかったんです
えっと その子供を産むことと存在欲との関連性はあるんでしょうか
それとそれと関連して
ウパーサカスッタっていうのがあるんですが
その中で子供を作ることに対して一生懸命助けなくてもいいよっていうようなことが書いてあるんですが
そのことについてはどう理解すればいいでしょうか
経典のことはちょっと私は原文を読まないと解説することは難しいんです
子供を作ることだけではなく
我々やっている一切の行為は存在欲と恐怖感なんです
はっきり言ってます それは
だから出家するときはもうすべて存在欲に関わるものを禁止されている
我々は結婚もしないし
私はやっちゃいますけど
出家には赤ちゃんを抱いてはいけません
私は結構子供を抱っこしたり
子供の面倒を見たりする経験があるんだから
よくわかるんですよ すごく穏やかな気持ちでいるんだけど
ちっちゃなちょこちょこちょこ遊び回っている子供が来てると
放っておけないでしょ
結局は だから面倒を見てあげたり
いろいろなことをやっていると
なんかどこかでもうこいつのことを心配してあげなくちゃいけないとか
なんか別なホルモンが生まれてくるんですよ
その別なホルモンが出てくると
まともに説法することもできなくなっちゃうんです
で スリランカに行ったら
国へ行ったらね もう結構子供たちがさーっと来て一緒に遊ぶんですね
たまたまどこかに説法に行ってくれたら
私は説法って嫌だなと思うんです
正直にやりたくないとかね
何喋ればいいか なぜかというと
頭が動かないんです もう体でもう子供のこと心配する
もうホルモンができちゃって
その時はこれはもう執着で良くないと私は知ってるんだから
もうすぐ帰ると全部きれいさっぱり捨てますけど
感情はね だから子供は抱いてはいけませんとかね
そこまで禁止しているのは
やっぱり心成長するまではそういうのはね
存在欲に関わるんだから
もう気をつけた方がいいんですね
世の中は人間が財産を築く
子孫を作る で 子孫がちゃんと結婚して孫まで作ってほしいやと
で 思ったりする これで自分が我が輩はよく頑張ったというくだらない満足感で死んじゃう
まあ平易に言えば無意味なんですね
私のもの 私のもの 私のものと言いたいだけの話なんですね
だから世の中はすべての世界は存在欲と恐怖感で生きているんです
それだけです はい  ありがとうございます
ございました まだ多分あると思うんですけど
時間がちょうど過ぎてしまいましたので
これで終了にしたいと思います
最後に回向の文を皆さんでお唱えして終了したいと思います
わかる方は一緒にお唱えください
合掌してください 回向の文仏法僧の三宝に帰依した
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナーによって生まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに廻向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして 苦悩が減らされますように
サッティーティヴェワ ジャントゥ サッバローグ ヴィナッシャトゥ マテー バワッタンタラーヨ スティ ディーガー ユコ バワ
バワトゥ サッバ マンガラム ラッカントゥ サッバ デーヴァター サッバ プンダーヌバーヴェーナ サッバ ダンマヌ
バーヴェーナ サッバ サンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー スッティー バワントゥ テ アビワダナシーリッセ ニッチャン ワッダ パチャヤーイナ
チャッターロ ダンマ ワッダンティ ホーイ ワンノハ スカン バラン
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
では ありがとうございます